what's going on guys
Batman V Superman the ultimate edition
it dropped last week 30 minutes of new
footage so what's new what's changed is
it a better movie we're gonna find out
today we got a couple of cool dudes talk
about it with first off you know this
guy he's the movie fights champion and
the host of summer movie report what's
up Dan Merle and ahh I want to thank him
for returning to the show he's an actor
a writer co-host of Marvel movie news
plays Andrew first off this cut of the
movie is rated R now as opposed to pg-13
it is it's not a hard art oh it's not a
hard R they add Italy got a little extra
blood got an f-bomb yep like one in
there you got a bat but uh huh okay it's
it's R but it doesn't change the tone of
the movie Superman drop an f-bomb
Superman does not drop it every not so
let's start talking about some of the
individual elements the moments in the
movie Africa Lois Lane is in Africa that
team of Superman there's some new
information divulged in that scene
there's exactly not in the theatrical
cut that's kind of just used as an
inciting incident yeah now it's like
there's a plot gotcha
because it seemed like Superman was
being framed for shooting people which
does not good
why would Superman shoot people here it
makes it very very evident what happened
that Lexus security forces burn the
bodies that they shot to make it appear
that Superman came through with the heat
vision and that he was kind of acting as
a vigilante loner stepping into
government affairs it absolutely does
fill in it felt more intentional and
less like oh this worked out Superman's
the bad guy yet more like he planned it
instead of him ending up being the net
yeah I wanna get more to Lex Luthor's
plan in a moment but uh back to the
Africa scene yeah we meet one of a
classic comic book character and that
has a title for 20 years and I get shot
in the face yeah Alex Jimmy Olsen is the
most important male character besides
Superman Superman I would say I would
say he's the most important yeah I mean
you got Superman's pal Jimmy Olsen he
had 20 years of comics like his own run
and then he's also been in all seven
years of Superman lore and they shoot
him in the face
in two minutes this is kind of another
example and kind of cements through this
ultimate cut that Zack Snyder is not
beholden
to any sort of cannon like cannon Lord
made his own mythology and he has cuz he
killed eels Jimmy also gets shot in the
face
Wow okay so let's pivot back to Lex
Luthor's plan Jesse Eisenberg does it
make more sense do we feel like the
pieces the machinations are in place I
don't think it fully makes sense but I
think it leads itself to think it makes
more sense yeah I mean I believe leads
into it starting to follow you there
well I think what quois getting at is
that Lex Luthor's plan is so sprawling
through in this film yeah the ultimate
cut does is you see even more of it so
for example you see that Lex invited
Clark Kent to the charity ball to meet
Bruce Wayne and I basically orchestrated
that meeting okay so um you'd leave me
to one of the pieces of the plan does it
feel more motivated that battle between
Batman and Superman do we feel like oh
they have more of a reason to square one
of the things we were talking about is
that you do but it is still negated by
the third act reveal of stealing the
mother like they're both sides have
plenty of reason to fight both sides
have been set up to fight for a thing
that ties in to their own belief system
but then they negate that entirely
because all they had to do was steal his
mom there's several minutes added of
Clark Kent being a reporter you see him
investigate the Batman and you see him
meeting the families of the the people
that Batman has been branding and you
see him kind of turning against him a
little bit because he's saying that he
is a vigilante and you also see that in
prison the people that get the brand get
killed again what'd you find out and
it's more of Lex Luthor's plan is that
Lex has been hiring prisoners to kill
anyone with that bat brand so is that
man look much more of a bad guy to
Superman right it makes him look like
that he is branding these criminals
because he knows that they will be
killed so that's interesting so Lex's is
more of a puppet master when it comes to
this school yes he talks about getting
out from under the shadow of his father
that he's kept the study exactly the
same because you know maybe that'll make
his dad come back and it's much more of
this kind of you see a little bit why
he's so eccentric because he's just this
broken boy
broken he's broken does he put more
candy in anyone's mouth but he's
doesn't like candy they still put the
Jolly Rancher in the mouth of a
memorable that was for everyone so uh
speaking of Lex there's a scene with who
most people are saying is Steppenwolf a
character that has been more or less
confirmed as the main Justice League big
bad this is the scene that dropped the
week after Batman V Superman Rizzoli's
yeah theater speak and it felt strange
in the film to me did it did it to you
all of a sudden we have this experience
where he stumbles onto this thing you're
like this feels important and it's gone
it's the most blatant example of I think
world building that they did I mean even
more than the Justice League stuff you
know that mean the Justice League stuff
you get gets called dawn of Justice you
have to set up the Justice League mm-hmm
did the dream sequence with the Darkseid
logo and the futuristic moment of Batman
and Superman did that feel more organic
did that feel more earned or well they
they discipline side of it yes they made
it clear that the troops that Batman was
fighting were his and that he was
double-crossed right by his people but
okay one of the men says he's sorry and
a totally different plot point
altogether and it sets up like that the
idea the manipulation from Superman's
side it sets ups Batman's paranoia more
it sets up the idea that Batman doesn't
know who he can trust there's a lot to
it with that slight reveal and another
character that was talked about but um
was not in the final cut
Jenna Malone's character uh so she's in
Ultimate Edition tell us about that
she's a lab technician her name is Jana
Clyburn who I think there's a minor
character from the comic books yeah and
she basically when they cut the Africa
storyline down way down they had to cut
her scenes because they were all in
relation to Lois's investigation of
Africa right so when that went away she
had to go away but then it created this
whole horribly and this giant paradox of
like why she wasn't there but also the
most important thing to me was that she
says a very important thing to the film
that was a giant plot point people got
upset about the explosive device in the
chair was lead-lined oh so Superman
wouldn't been able to see it because it
was lined with lay Wow and she says that
but since they had to cut her earlier
scene it wouldn't make sense for her to
just pop in and say it so by cutting her
it created this giant whirlwind puddle
to things in that Washington testimony
scene he should have said there's a bomb
net wheelchair
and he should have said don't drink that
Pete Maravich the theatrical cut the
capital explodes and Superman looks at
Lois Lane and just flies away and people
are going like what so man like a lot of
people injured and in this one the scene
begins with Superman flying down he has
up he has an injured person with him he
gives it to a firefighter and he says
like here and he's trying to help and
the firefighter says you know the
persons died and he's like help feels
like he's in the way and he was to blame
already and then he looks around there's
body bags that whole scene has much more
emotional content because you're caring
right do we feel like this gives
Superman a little bit more compassion
and that kind of it well he's not a
human but that humanity that uh we we
want in our inner city is it helped
there's a scene where Clark where he
calls his mom and talks to her a little
bit and I was like really late she's
worried then he just says like hi in a
movie as complex as Batman to Superman
when you need to make a cut the first
thing you're going to cut our character
beans because they're superfluous to the
plot supposedly when you have 30 minutes
of them gone that's when it adds up to a
fence up to some it adds up to a watch
one of my absolute favorite things about
the movie where I thought ooh they
nailed this in some moments was the
actual fight the action in the movie
there was some kickass moments how's the
action in this version has it improved
different that's the one that is really
sad I think they knew they had that
right they couldn't get rid of any so
they act at all there's more arm
snapping there's some more blood sprays
and a little more violent it would
probably would have pushed the edge of a
pg-13 yeah it's again it's not gory
people aren't just drenched in blood
there's not guts hanging out okay a
little more all right talk to me about
the Martha moment did that resonate more
the Martha moment still there I think
Diane Lane having more scenes helped you
care about Martha whether or not that
the Martha moment it's still subjective
of how you feel about it are there any
other moments or tidbits that weren't in
the first that we've left out there's
one little thing that leaves the door
open that I loved when Batman confronts
lex luthor at the end of the movie he
says there are places that take care of
the mentally ill you're not going to one
of these places i've arranged that
you're going to get transferred to
Arkham Asylum I still have some friends
there and so it sets up
that Lex is going to Arkham which is
brilliant world building and it's subtle
and it shows how long Batman's been
Batman and also because he clearly has
controlled the prisons because we saw
that so it's great that Batman's putting
in a place where he is controlled this
opens up Lex being in Suicide Squad
absolutely yeah hundred sings there's no
way they're avoiding Arkham and Suicide
Squad it gives us a Lex Luthor that can
be the Emperor Palpatine of this is
Snyder versi oh behind the scenes toying
yeah I like that comparison yeah uh
although I don't know if Disney will
like that compare let's get a
bottom-line it here if you love the
movie what's it gonna do for you if you
weren't a fan will it make you a fan if
you love the movie I think you'll like
it more if you didn't like the movie the
solve some problems but it doesn't solve
a lot of the core problems people had
with it it just clarifies things if
you're a fan of Snyder's Superman you'll
love this and if you're not it won't
change that gotcha
guys thank you for unpacking that have
you seen the Batman V Superman Ultimate
Edition are you looking forward to it
what do you think about that scene with
Jesse Eisenberg putting a piece of candy
in a guy's mouth let us know in the
comment section below I want to thank a
couple of swell fellas for being here
Dan Merle
thanks for coming across the hall
anytime boys and ro great having you
back thanks man I don't want to thank
you for watching I'm Hal hrodna kicked
me up on Twitter bye bye Batman and
Wonder Woman recruiting metahumans just
give us a quick description what is a
metahuman it's super is a super hero for
a couple of years Marvel and DC had
tried to own the trademark of the word
Supergirl so metahuman was a term that
was in use when there was a debate over
the trademark yeah it's one of those
words that it really just means that
these are people who have abilities
that's all